hey ice compressed now that I've deleted
my channel let's look at some top
craters on the site now so I can catch
up I need to learn how they do it how do
they get in the suggestion bar I need to
watch and study carefully to find out I
want to get a hundred thousand likes in
this video I know I know it's crazy so
hit that like match that like play smash
demolish fifteen thousand lights on this
video that would be absolutely amazing
honestly that's an absolutely incredible
goal that's a freakin crazy god I don't
know if you could do it honestly if we
could hit that goal you just made me
like the happiest person ever literally
you want to know the best optical
illusion of all time that I'm gonna tell
you right now if you actually go ahead
and click the like button it turns blue
honestly you have to try it try it right
now it's it's the it's the most crazy
thing you ever see on youtube drop a
like in this video we can get 30,000
likes Magic's about to go on and maybe
just maybe they're gonna let me join
your scam group you guys know that I
always need good luck so I need you guys
to go down to that like button right now
and hit it we've been getting 50,000
links on all of my videos so go hit that
like button and apparently this magic
trick doesn't work if you don't get 50k
like so I mean you don't need anything
hey yo what is up 50 million likes can
we hit it on this video Danny DeVito
will you suck my dick in 50 million
likes can we [ __ ] do it
what is good 50 million fresh fun like
bunnies right down there I know you've
seen it what are you buying like my face
50 million looks do you think 50 million
is too much yeah what about a million 1
million likes
ah destroy that like button like I
destroyed your mama's [ __ ]
romanian million likes or I'll kill it
or the dog you want this Apple you like
it you like before you try it how else
will you know if you like it it's 2016 1
million likes or I'll kill myself
I don't even know who I am anymore
[Music]